Vous m'avez manqué...
*Rire*
Ouah, ça fait bizarre !
Ça fait longtemps ! Ça fait presque un mois que j'ai pas tourné dans ce studio, mon gars.
J'suis content d'être de retour !
*Soupir*
Merde, ils m'ont peut-être oublié...
Je sais plus du tout ce qu'ils pensent de moi.
Comment je vais faire, moi, pour avoir confiance en moi
sans savoir ce que les gens pensent ?
Oh putain ! J'suis dans la merde !
Après un mois sans vidéos !
Un mois sans tourner !
Un mois loin de YouTube !
Les gens m'ont peut-être oublié !
Je ne sais plus ce que vous pensez de moi,
je ne sais plus où nous en sommes dans notre RELATION,
mais j'ai trouvé un MOYEN de faire le point.
Connaissez-vous le site SensCritique ?
*Squeezie-Voix-off* Le site propose de découvrir, de noter, et de commenter des œuvres culturelles dans plusieurs domaines :
films, séries télévisées, livres, bandes dessinées, albums et morceaux musicaux, jeux vidéos...
et YouTubeurs~♪ ! Oui oui oui !
Mes vidéos sont donc des œuvres culturelles ! *Rire*
Les amis, il y a quelques années, j'avais découvert ce site,
et il y avait pas mal de critiques à l'encontre des YouTubeurs
et les critiques à mon encontre étaient surtout négatives.
Alors on va les lire pour faire le point sur notre relation,
savoir où nous en sommes.
Finalement, un petit peu, c'est comme si on allait voir un psy pour couple,
sauf qu'y a pas de psy !
Alors, intervenants, Lucas Hauchard Squeezie.
Avec une photo de 2013, merci !
*Rire* Y'a rien qui va ! J'adore !
Je suis acteur et auteur, merci, ça fait du bien à mon égo,
mais je suis pas du tout né le 20 janvier 96 ! *Rire*
Pourtant c'était pas compliqué à trouver !
En tapant mon nom sur Google on le trouve tout de suite !
C'est parti pour lire les critiques ! Il y a 37 critiques.
J'crois qu'il y a eu des critiques depuis 2013, 2014,
donc ça sera pas euh...
ça parlera pas des mêmes choses en fonction de la période.
Quoi qu'il en soit, ce sont des gens qui ont pris du temps pour écrire quelque chose à mon égard,
et rien que pour ça, je suis touché !
Même si c'est négatif !
Y'a une démarche de bienveillance qui est certaine.
A mon avis !
Alors, la première c'est de Neah.
*Lecture du commentaire*
*Bruit de vitre cassée*
*Bruit de coups de feu*
Ouah, la première phrase elle me met tellement cher, gros !
*Lecture du commentaire*
Clément, viens t’asseoir, j'te laisse, allez vas-y !
Tu peux garder les revenus de la chaîne avec, je pars avec Natsu par contre, ciao !
*Lecture du commentaire*
*Lecture du commentaire avec une musique émotionnelle en fond*
Oui vas-y Neah, continue comme ça, t'es sur la bonne voie !
T'as raison, Neah ! T'as une culture de dingue !
T'es même l'une personne qui en a le plus de France !
*Lecture du commentaire avec une musique émotionnelle en fond*
*Bruit de disque rayé* Putain ! Ça te rappelle toujours un truc débile !
J'peux pas te rappeler un truc sympa, quoi ?
Un sentiment bien ?
Ça te rappelle toujours un truc débile, c'est triste quoi !
*Lecture du commentaire*
Attends-ten-ten, ça part en débat politique sur le public de SensCritique, là !
Je... je... je, moi, je me mêle pas à ça hein ! Je connais pas, je sais pas !
*Lecture du commentaire avec de la musique classique en fond*
Ouaaais, grave ! Grave ! J'ai compris la réf et tout...
De ouf !
*Bruit de déglutition*
*Lecture du commentaire avec de la musique classique en fond*
Vas-y Neah ! Vas-y !
Vas-y Neah !!! Ohhhh !!!
*Lecture du commentaire avec de la musique classique en fond*
Nan ça c'est toi Clément !
Nan ça, y'a rien de compliqué !
*Lecture du commentaire avec de la musique classique épique en fond*
Alors fais tomber ta plume, et dis-moi la note que je mérite, Neah !
7 ! C'est mieux que la plupart des notes que j'avais au lycée !
Après, je fais ça pour le fun, moi, les critiques ça m'atteint pas, jm'en fous de la note, 'fin, vous voyez bien !
Par exemple, j'vais pas envoyer un message à Carlito pour lui dire que j'suis noté 7/10, 'fin, ça a aucun sens !
*Bruit d'envoi de message*
Neah, sa critique elle est géniale, parce qu'il m'a mis des grosses balles quand même dans la tête, tu vois.
Il m'a un peu planté avec son couteau comme ça,
hop, hop, hop ! *bruit de couteau à chaque coup*
Et après qu'est-ce qu'il a fait, mec ?
Il a mis la pommade, le petit pansement sur la pommade,
ET, il s'arrête pas là, il m'a fait un petit bisou sur le front. *Bruit de bisou*
Voilà ce qu'il a fait !
Neah, j'espère que tu vas bien !
Alors, nouvelle critique publiée par Yuriku le 17 février 2016 :
*Lecture du commentaire*
Ah d'accord !
Ah, Yurikutu tu t'es trompé, il faut aller sur GameCulte ou jeuvideo.com ou un autre truc en fait !
Et comme ça t'auras le son du jeu en plus !
Le pauvre, il croit qu'y'a que moi qui parle de jeux !
*Rire*
Oh ! Raichu, le 28 décembre 2014, qui nous dit :
*Lecture du commentaire*
Ouaaah, mec j'espère que tu vas mieux !
Il neige ?
Oh c'est du SEL !
*Lecture du commentaire*
Bah, mec, j'vois pas de quoi tu parles déjà !
Bah, arrêtez, soyez un peu objectifs, ils ont tous au moins dix-ans ans, là !
*Lecture du commentaire*
Ouah attends, là y'a une tempête de sel ! Gros, t'as créé une tempête de sel !
En vrai, je troll mais je le comprend un peu Raichu !
C'est qu'à l'époque les salaires des YouTubeurs, des gros YouTubeurs, commençaient à se faire connaître.
Puisqu'on fait souvent l’amalgame, on croit souvent que c'est tous les YouTubeurs
qui gagnent énormément d'argent,
alors que pas du tout ! On est une poignée à très bien gagner notre vie,
c'est vrai, mais y'en a plein, à côtés qui gagnent beaucoup moins,
et y'en a encore plus qui galèrent à en vivre !
Du coups, c'était assez nouveau à l'époque, d'apprendre que...
des mecs qui se filment en jouant aux jeux vidéos gagnent des sommes... assez élevées !
Et du coup, ça a créé beaucoup de jalousie et de frustration.
Et c'est totalement compréhensible !
Alors, je peux pas lui en vouloir à Raichu !
*Lecture du commentaire*
Raichu, j'espère que t'as pas fini sourd ou malentendant à cause de moi.
Au quel cas, je comprendrais la violence de ta critique, et je m'excuse !
*Lecture du commentaire*
*Rire*
A bon entendeur ?!
Raichu, je ne peux pas t'en vouloir, tu es le bienvenu dans le studio, si un jour tu passes par là un de ces quatre,
n'hésite pas.
En tout cas, j'envoie ton numéro à Macron, qui, l’hiver prochain
quand 'y aura re du givre et tout,
te demandera t'écrire quelques critiques pour dégivrer les routes, hein !
Grâce à ton sel !
C'EST pas drôle !
Bon hé ! Je reviens de vacances, laissez-moi me re-roder un peu là...
Je sais que vous avez été habitués à un peu mieux quand-même !
Nouvelle critique de Ash, le 18 septembre 2015 :
*Lecture du commentaire*
Ça commence bien, 'fin..
Ok, ok, bah au moins il y a quelques sourires déjà !
*Lecture du commentaire*
Ok bah tu... C'est vrai ?!
*Lecture du commentaire avec une musique émotionnelle en fond*
Attends, Ash ! Tu vas dire que tu vas peut-être sauver ma carrière ?!
Euh, j'vais être direct, j'ai été assez surpris par la tournure bizarre de la tournure bizarre
de certaines de ses phrases dans sa critique !
"Celle des catacombes de Paris m'avais beaucoup plu !"
*Lecture du commentaire avec une musique émotionnelle en fond*
Ouais, bon ça va aussi, euh, vas-y !
Alors, critique de SatanOfficiel.
Oh putain de merde !
La dernière fois que je l'ai vu, c'était pour signer un pacte me menant à la réussite de ma carrière sur YouTube !
*Lecture du commentaire*
*Bruit d'éclair*
*Rire*
J'reviens d'entre les morts pour rire parce que c'est quand même bien écrit !
*Lecture du commentaire*
*Rire*
C'est si violent !
En fait, j'étais vraiment la télé réalité de YouTube à l'époque !
J'ai l'impression qu'à l'époque tout le monde savait que c'était pas très fufu, un peu exagéré, un peu pourri et tout,
mais tout le monde regardait quand même,
parce que ça faisait du bien de se vider la tête et de pas faire marcher le cerveau quand on regardait ces vidéos-là !
Et c'est exactement le même discours que les gens qui regardent la télé-réalité ont ! C'est trop drôle !
*Lecture du commentaire*
Pardon Satan !
J'voulais te rendre honneur après notre pacte, mais apparemment ça ne marche pas !
Tu me détestes !
Nouvelle critique, écrite par Souttia le 26 mai 2018, oh c'est récent !
*Lecture du commentaire*
*Rire*
J'suis désolé pour la voix que je fais, mais ça ressemble à des phrases de voix-off de télé
et ça c'est une voix-off de télé pour moi. Bref.
*Lecture du commentaire*
Eh, vous avez vu, ma voix a changé ?!
Comme il me fait un compliment ?
Ah, j'suis pas objectif, c'est horrible !
*Lecture du commentaire*
qui étaient des oeuvres culturelles, euh, hors du commun.
*Cri de douleur puis rire dans la vidéo*
*Lecture du commentaire*
Oh, ça ! Je te le fais pas dire !
*Rire*
"Ces derniers temps, il s'est lancé dans des vlogs, des jeux de sociétés et autres vidéos détentes avec son entourage"
*Lecture du commentaire*
Ouaaah !
7 ! Merci Souttia. Si tu as besoin de "sous, ti-a" mon numéro !
*Bruits de criquets*
Chers amis, il est maintenant temps de lire la dernière critique :
Larmesdeplomb, le 14 septembre 2017
Le D.U.C de Youtube !
Ah j'sens ça va être du second degré bien drôle ! Allez on y va !
*Lecture du commentaire*
*Rire*
Ah, l'bâtard !
Ah, il me flingue direct !
*Lecture du commentaire*
J'vous le rappelle, que ça, c'est une critique sur moi.
Je sais on dirait pas, on dirait une thèse, vraiment. Mais c'est sur moi !
*Lecture du commentaire*
"Humoriste avéré avec ses nouveaux compares Maxenss, Macfly et Carlito et tant d'autres !
Il sortira des vlogs de futur, fera des vols en ZéroG, n'hésitera pas à dis Hanouna malgré sa fanbase très active sur les réseaux et bien plus."
*Lecture du commentaire*
10 sur 10 !
Larmesdeplomb, je suis peut-être le duc de Youtube
mais tu es le duc de SensCritique !
C'est magnifique !
Les amis ! C'est la fin de cette vidéo sur SensCritique.
Vous savez quoi, c'est une idée de vidéo que j'avais eue, j'crois en 2015.
Mais comme y'avait que des critiques négatives
et que j'étais un peu plus fragile psychologiquement, j'avais moins confiance en moi, etc,
j'me cherchais un peu,
bah j'avais pas eu trop le courage de la faire et j'ai bien fait,
j'pense que ça m'aurait ANNIHILÉ.
J'aurais été en PLS dans mon lit, mon gars, pendant deux semaines
J'suis trop content d'avoir lu toutes ces critiques avec vous, c'est trop rigolo?
c'est bien écrit, même si y'a pas mal de trucs négatifs,
des fois il y a des gens qui sont quand même un peu trop salés...
Mais y'a quand même beaucoup de gens que je trouve très objectifs et qui disent des trucs assez vrais, en vrai !
Hé ben, merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo !
J'espère que cette petite vidéo retour vous aura plu.
J'avais pas envie de faire une vidéo thread pour le retour, j'voulais faire une vidéo un peu...
où on s'parle, on dit des trucs ensemble, voilà, c'est plus rigolo pour ce retour,
et puis la prochaine fois,
je crois qu'y'a une p'tite vidéo un peu thread, pas vraiment un thread mais un truc euh...
Ah on va pas dormir !
On va re-pas dormir, j'suis désolé !
J'vous fais des gros bisous, j'vous dis à bientôt,
j'suis content d'être de retour !
J'espère que vous êtes contents aussi d'être de retour au taf ou en cours, même si j'ai des doutes.
Comptez sur moi pour vous divertir un maximum jusqu'aux prochaines grandes vacances  !
Plein de bonnes choses pour vous, j'espère que vous êtes bien reposés, que vous êtes au top
et que vous attaquez la rentrée avec de l'énergie, avec de l'envie,
et puis voilà, j'vous souhaite le meilleur et je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo.
Big Bisou !
J'ai osé dire Big Bisou !
C'qui est très moyen !
Au revoir.
*Bip*
Attention, c'est pas encore fini !
J'profite de la fin de cette vidéo pour revenir pour la première et dernière fois
sur le tweet que j'avais fait début août
parce que je tiens à m'excuser.
Ce qui m'a poussé à faire ce tweet,
c'est des vrais témoignages poignants qui dénonçaient les actes honteux d'une minorité de YouTubeurs,
et pas tous, attention !
Comme vous avez pu le lire, la plupart des noms des gens à qui je pensais au moment du tweet
sont sortis dans la presse.
Ces histoires vont maintenant être réglées devant la vraie justice,
parce qu'elle a ce qu'il faut comme preuves,
mais pas devant celle de Twitter.
Mais y'a un point où j'ai complètement merdé
et c'est pour ça que je reviens là-dessus :
en ne donnant aucun nom pour des raisons légales, ça a créé un malentendu général
et c'est devenu pour certains une sorte de une chasse aux sorcières, un p'tit jeu très malsain.
Y'a pas mal de personnes qui sont même allées jusqu'à créer des photomontages de fausses conversations,
à créer des memes, à faire des blagues de mauvais goût...
et j'pense qu'on devrait pas trop rire d'un sujet qui est aussi... grave, en fait.
Et la conséquence de tout ça,
c'est l'immense diffamation que certains YouTubeurs ont subi à cause de moi.
Ça a entaché leur image à tord
et ils se sont pris la haine gratuite d'un bon paquet de gens mal intentionnés
qui voulaient juste récupérer des RTs et du buzz en foutant le bordel en fait,
mais qui s'en foutaient complètement de la cause.
J'pense par exemple à Norman, que je visais pas du tout,
et qui s'est quasiment tout pris gratuitement dans la gueule.
Alors beaucoup de personnes pensent que j'ai pas à être responsable de la réaction des gens face à mon tweet,
moi j'pense que j'ai ma part de responsabilité là-dedans, et c'est pour ça que je reviens sur ce sujet aujourd'hui.
J'm'excuse auprès des YouTubeurs qui ont pris la tempête de Twitter et de ces rageux.
C'était vraiment pas mon intention, donc j'espère que ça n'a eu aucun impact sur vous, aucune conséquence.
Maintenant, on ferme le sujet !
Le sujet est clos !
La justice, la vraie justice a tout ce qu'il faut pour reprendre la relève, n'vous en faîtes pas !
Et j'pense que tout le monde, à sa manière, tire sa propre leçon de cette histoire.
Donc ça serait cool que maintenant YouTube ça redevienne un espace de créativité,
de bonnes ondes et de bienveillance.
Voilà !
Cette fois, c'est la vraie fin de la vidéo,
donc on peut... cliquer sur une autre...
Au revoir !
♫ Outro ♫